there's a lot of major investors all
across the financial markets who want to
invest in bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
but they keep saying i need regulatory
clarity in order to actually start to
allocate capital to this new industry
now one of the questions is will these
assets fall under securities law or will
they be treated as commodities gary
ginsler the chairman of the sec was on
cnbc this morning and he explicitly
stated that bitcoin and only bitcoin is
the only asset that he is willing to
clearly state is not a security bitcoin
is a commodity and ultimately what that
means is that bitcoin has regulatory
clarity as we see more and more
investors start to wrap their heads
around this we should see
more of them get comfortable allocating
capital to the bitcoin industry now that
leaves the other 20 000 coins out there
that have been created what is gonna
happen to them are they securities or
are they not gary had a lot to say about
them as well here's the clip from this
morning on cnbc you have been uh adamant
that there should be a some degree
of coordination with the cftc and you
about trying to make it so that we have
a more clarity let's say on uh
cryptocurrency where where's the state
of play crypto right now look this this
is a highly speculative aspect class uh
we've known this for uh a long time the
ups and downs of this speculative uh
asset class bitcoin and hundreds of
other
tokens and
many of these tokens
offer the investing public uh or the
investing public is hoping i should say
hoping for a return just like when they
invest in in other financial assets we
cost securities and many of these
financial assets crypto financial assets
uh have the key attributes of the
security so some of them they're under
the securities and exchange commission
some
like bitcoin and that's the only one jim
i'm going to say
my predecessors and others have said
they're they're a commodity and right
now you have hundreds if not thousands
of these crypto tokens that have the
basic attributes of raising money from
the public and having a group of
entrepreneurs that you might have on
your show saying come hither we've
we've got a good idea for you and and
that's okay in america if you comply
with the laws and we've got
unfortunately a lot of projects that are
non-compliant
so as you can see here it's very clear
in the minds of the sec chairman bitcoin
is not a security it is a commodity all
of the other coins according to him
majority of them actually are securities
they're acting like securities and
therefore they should be ruled under
securities law now that means that
there's a lot of people who issued these
securities and didn't register that
probably are trying to figure out what
they should do now it also means that a
lot of investors were told you're buying
something that's not a security and now
all of a sudden that may actually not
have been true but at the end of the day
regulatory clarity is really important
just remember that clarity does not mean
you get the ruling that you want simply
means that there's clarity that everyone
is told what the rules are and everyone
agrees to abide by those rules
and so bitcoin being out in front being
the most decentralized digital currency
making sure that there is regulatory
clarity that the sec the cftc and others
all agree bitcoin is not a security and
as cz the ceo and founder of binance
told me on twitter this morning there's
not a single jurisdiction in the world
that i or him are aware of where bitcoin
is classified as a security
everyone believes that it is a commodity
and that means that regulatory clarity
should give confidence to investors who
want to allocate to the space now
there's a whole bunch of other factors
everything from the macro environment to
the federal reserve monetary policy that
would either encourage or deter
participation in the bitcoin industry
but when you look at the regulatory
front the clarity that is being provided
now is an important step to more and
more investors especially financial
institutions public corporations and
eventually nation states getting
comfortable with the asset and gaining
some sort of exposure to it make sure
that you do your own research whenever
you're actually looking at assets
especially in the crypto industry but
here it is clear from the sec chairman
bitcoin is not a security it's a
commodity and that ends up probably
being a very big tailwind for the most
decentralized digital currency in the
world hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time